that's a great advice what what else on
here
um anything else we're missing I don't
know what did they say I did do we put
friend groups on there because I think
oh yeah that's that's so true yeah you
know I there's this girl I follow I want
to do reaction to it okay
um no I didn't well I didn't maybe maybe
I could show you actually but but she um
I followed this girl her name's like
bunny on Tick Tock and she's a big age
Gap right she's dating a guy like 25
years older okay and I just saw the slow
evolution of her being married and she
moved to LA to like pursue the Social
Media stuff
and then she started hanging out with
some other single moms and then they
started going to all these events and I
just remember like watching in real time
thinking this girl is gonna get divorced
because she's not acting like the wife
no like she's wearing these scandily
clothed outfits and I'm just like
she's she's and she I just saw a video
of her crying on Tick Tock talking about
she got divorced and I was yeah and I
was thinking the friend group's
important so what are you gonna say
about friend groups right I think it's
important to know who's going to be in
your circle and share that with your
spouse so you know he may ask you to cut
off some male friends or some
girlfriends that aren't really helping
you be your best self
um if you have expectations or you like
to do I don't know girls trips or guys
trips or you know go out all of that has
to be talked about and I would say if
he's not a fan of it you should lay it
down because ultimately he's the one
responsible for you
wow
it's the one what else
I'm gonna milk you for all the
information I see because this is super
this is actually super helpful you're
bringing up a lot of stuff I never even
thought about oh well thank you
um you know we we talked about health I
think uh in addition to the food any
Habits Like how much you drink if you
smoke if you do any of that kind of
stuff you know you shouldn't assume that
people are you know just okay with it
hopefully you treat your body well but
if you like to do anything you know
recreationally
um
I would advise highly advise against it
but you know you just want to be on the
same page you don't want someone saying
oh it's natural and someone's saying I
don't want you to put that in your body
when I was married my ex-husband didn't
even want me to use certain lotions when
I was expecting because he didn't want
you know anything too strong on the baby
and I said does that make sense to me
but you know what it doesn't have to
make sense to me I'm gonna let it go
this is not the hill I'm trying to die
on
drink if you smoke yeah any of that kind
of stuff what else
ah let's see do you listen to Pearl
um
goodness if you feel like this is it
then you can I think this is pretty good
I don't know if anybody else to say
anything if anything else comes to they
said it's about facts not I feel like I
know sometimes when I think when I talk
I say I feel like oh yeah
um let's see willing to compromise
um if single mothers apply must provide
character reference and be transparent
about the relationship status with the
co-parents of the child
what do you do under stressful
situations they said yeah yeah I think
we talked about the stressful situations
uh in that communication section knowing
how you handle that but I do agree I
mean we talked about this yesterday I'm
not necessarily a believer that that big
beautiful blended family is always the
best thing I know it can work but it's
extremely hard so I'm not doing that but
I do agree if you do have children or if
there's any other thing that you're
attached to what is the relationship
with the other parent because even if
they're just you know happily
um
going along things change when when you
get married we talked about that
yesterday and someone may say you know
well I don't want that person around my
kids you just kind of know what you're
walking into so that's why I kind of you
know beware yeah so you talked about
earlier the types of marriages that's
what so you said executive marriage or
political political marriage right and
and for me that's just the type of
marriage you know we had a certain
president and I'm not saying anything
politically but if you have a president
a senator a governor maybe this is
someone that was selected for them to
help soften their masculine image but
they may go their separate marriage
um is it you know a marriage for papers
you know maybe it's like an immigration
situation that you all agree this is
what we're gonna do uh it could be a
military marriage where you know you
want somebody to be
um you know yours when you come back
home but they're gonna have to live I
don't know 11 12 months alone I think
when we say marriage we have and
um an understanding of what it means to
us but we have to make sure that the
person we're marrying wants that same
type of marriage because if he wants to
just be like is my dinner ready and then
you go your way and I go my way and you
really want somebody to buy bond with
and laugh with you guys are thinking
about marriage completely differently
and none is better than others but you
just got to make sure that the type of
wife or husband that you want to be
matches with the type of marriage that
you want to have
um is there anything so traditional
marriage military marriage papers
marriage political marriage Kevin
Samuels would always talk about like an
executive wife what's an executive
marriage
um so the executive wife you know I see
a little bit of that in me so that is
usually maybe a second marriage or when
someone's older and there aren't going
to be children involved right so you are
basically
um marrying maybe a one percent or a
type of man or a high value man that
needs you to be a support system to him
uh be the feminine asset to support his
brand make sure you can conduct yourself
in any circumstance we used to hear on
Kevin's show a lot of times Well I can
get together when well no he kind of
needs you to be on all the time because
you never know when someone is going to
call you and say hey we're doing this
thing so the executive marriage is
really
um not the like soccer mom which I love
that there was a time for that but
second time around for me it would be
more of a support system to a high value
man
and then are we gonna put modern
marriage in here too yeah that one I'm
not too well versed in but I know
there's different types of marriages and
they're you know Millennials and other
people who get married and maybe the 50
50 can work the only thing I would say
about that circling back to what we said
20 years from now if you're working 40
hours and he's working 40 hours and
maybe you all choose not to have
children and you just use your
disposable income to travel and all that
I would still say as a woman you're
going to want to slow it down and to a
man the way he looks at it is wait a
minute you're flipping the script on me
you said we were going to ride this out
we're gonna go 40 years hard in the
paint I'm still going you know saddle up
let's go and you're kind of like oh man
6 a.m again do we have to do it and it's
hard to see that far ahead when you're
in your 20s but you know with
communication uh you can make it work if
you don't want to have children you need
to say that don't lead anybody down that
path if that's not what you want yeah
but gosh that is such a great point with
the I never thought about the like later
in life like women aren't going to want
to work as much yeah so even if it's 50
50 now it doesn't mean it'll be 50 50
forever exactly what do you think
um
what do you think about do you think
women should be entitled to money after
marriage entitled no
um like what do you think about child
support of alimony like what's your
what's your opinion on that stuff so I
have to tread lightly here because I
know there are a lot of people that you
know this is their situation and and I
understand believe me so alimony is just
money to
um
make sure that a woman is not destitute
I think it has turned into you know I
hit the lottery so let's talk about
alimony and I am a believer you know in
prenup so this is something that you
have to talk about but if a woman the
way I believe and I'm no attorney but I
believe that if it was a woman that was
a stay-at-home mom she gave up her
career dedicated herself to the family
she's been out of the workforce for 20
years and for whatever reason the
marriage ends if she's not able to get
right back into it for a period of time
um
I hate alimony because that's kind of
enforced but I understand why it's there
I would hope that you know not all
divorces have to be horrible and if you
have the type of relationship where you
were a good woman you know to this man I
would think he would want to make sure
the mother of his children is not
destitute so I think most men it's just
like when the girls start to get crazy
oh my goodness yeah like I think a lot I
got girls would get a lot well I don't
they probably wouldn't get a lot more
because of the legal structure but I
think like I think of uh my grandparents
have um one side were separated and it
was funny because they're separated but
they just like still acted like they
were married absolutely absolutely I
mean it's doable my ex-husband and I a
lot of the boys teachers didn't even
know that we were divorced we would show
up at the events together parent-teacher
conference I'm putting stuff on his
calendar like it doesn't have to be bad
if you know that okay the marriage isn't
working but you still are you know good
people to each other I just think most
if it's reasonable I think that most men
would want to make sure that you're okay
but that means that okay you know what
maybe I need to go back to school and
get a certificate maybe it's going to
take me 18 months or I'm going to start
working part time and then get my way
back up like you have to come with
something you can't just sit back and
say take care of me until you know
forever that that's just me I know a lot
of people have strong opinions about
that but I'm a boy mom so I see things
differently now I'm very passionate
about that so after observing me for a
couple days what what do I need to
improve on the most are you sure you
want it I'm not gonna get banned no you
I can take it okay well I have to start
we'll do the compliment sandwich like I
said yesterday and I mean it you really
really are driven to get things right
and I think that's great you are a
little scattered uh sometimes when I
watch your streams it's a little bit all
over the place and I've had to work on
that communication I've gotten feedback
that I shout when I talk so I've had to
really work on making sure that Michael
you've got such a soft voice so it's
like thank you that is a huge compliment
because I used to be a little bit all
over the place too so like we said in
the beginning you can get better
um I really wish your attire was ah I
knew I knew this was coming I knew this
was coming I mean Melanie's helping me
this week on the fashion up thank you
Melanie get here when you come in
Melanie's coming okay and just because
I've had to work on that too I
understand especially as uh either moms
or I know you're an athlete sometimes we
just want to dress for comfort and I got
that feedback too that I would just wear
kind of what was comfortable and baggy
and it just didn't represent me well and
especially as you know since I have
whale Tendencies I got to make sure that
I represent myself well I used to think
oh it's so much work I got to do all
that it's not I did work with the
stylist I had to hire someone to help me
understand my body type and what works
well and kind of put like a capsule
wardrobe in place that you kind of make
a uniform for yourself these things work
on me and it's kind of rinse and repeat
so getting there was a little hard but
you can definitely do it so
communication a little bit more direct
um
the attire because we're talking about
getting Pearl ready for a husband right
no I that's close I know I need to get
better okay it's like I get so
overwhelmed sometimes you do a lot this
is a lot
because I'll be like getting ready and
I'm just like I can't get anything that
looks good and then I just give up
because I get so frustrated absolutely
because I'll spend like 10 minutes and
I'll hate everything and I'm like yeah
that's one of the exercises we had to do
it was hard she made me take everything
out of my closet and she said try it on
so I had to put everything on make sure
it fit make sure I still liked it and I
had to be able to wear it with like
three other different things like make
outfits from it and if it didn't meet
that category we got rid of it so it
really thinned some things down so yeah
I understand on that
um let's see
after a couple days
um
those will probably be my only two have
you asked your your audience what they
think you should improve on yeah what
should I oh I do have one more thing I
already I think I know go ahead well
okay two more things uh yesterday when I
was pushing you to get the plates ready
because the kids had uh um friends over
and everybody was hungry and uh you know
I was like come on Pearl in mom mode the
family's hungry and they're looking at
you do you remember what you said
you're right okay I do care about the
kids you do care I do I do love the kids
okay I just thought it was funny it was
kind of funny so you do uh language is
one thing you you do kind of drop the
f-bombs and you know a few other choice
words but I should have known when I
arrived yesterday and you know it's me
and then all I hear is Pearl saying are
the strippers here yet and I was like
wait a minute what did I get myself into
um which if you want to see the stripper
interview go to Auntie Jenny's Channel
yeah so that uh interview was happening
like next door while I was cooking and
when she was done you invited her in the
kitchen to come eat and it was just like
hi I'm Maggie it was yeah yeah she did
she was nice she was really nice and uh
yeah the only other thing oh you really
want me to say it hey okay
um sometimes your gestures are a bit
masculine okay and I don't know if it's
like the sport thing like you do like
you talk with your hands I do is that
masculine it can be it's a little bit
all over the place and so it's not as um
well like yesterday you may or may not
remember when you were cutting the steak
and you were talking to me with the fork
and you were kind of like
stabbing the air oh no no
okay I'm done I'm done
I do I I know actually as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible